quand j'étais en train d'écrire
Starmania avec berger un jour j'ai
répondu au téléphone il vient de voir
qui a dit ici Françoise Hardy et à
chaque fois je pense j'ai vraiment pensé
que c'était un gag et deux jours après
j'étais chez moi et alors je lui ai fait
une chanson je lui ai fait de Françoise
Hardy
bonsoir alors en 1976 tu as reçu un coup
de téléphone de Michel Berger te
proposant d'écrire un opéra rock c'était
pas une comédie musicale c'est tout
chanté un autre arabe un opéra rock sur
Patricia hurts j'ai travaillé un petit
peu puis ça a rien donné et puis
finalement vous avez fini par faire
Starmania quoi maintenant j'ai pas voulu
faire des histoires de Patricia d'abord
parce qu'on savait pas encore on
connaissait pas la fin encore
mais en fait elle n'était pas
décrire en français une histoire d'une
Américaine ça me gênait parce que je
suis québécois parce que sinon
c'est un très bon sujet mais maintenant
qu'on connaît la fin je trouve que c'est
encore le meilleur sujet
[Applaudissements]
de télévision qui s'enfuit avec un
terroriste alors finalement vous avez
fait starmaniables ça a été créé il y a
10 ans à Paris et puis la production
était un peu lourde la salle un peu un
peu grande il faut bien le dire et ça
pas été le succès que vous escomptiez
quoi
pendant un mois on a 2300 plus bas mais
bon mais après c'était fini donc c'était
frustrant parce que quand on écrit
évidemment un opéra ou une comédie
musicale on veut que ça dure on a envie
que ça soit joué longtemps et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on leur montre
enfin là il y a beaucoup d'Anglais
d'Américains qui sont venus voir
Starmania et qui et on sait qu'on va le
faire en anglais ça c'est un scoop ah
oui c'est un scoop déjà j'arrive donc la
terre avec berger on sait qu'on va le
faire à Londres l'année prochaine et
ensuite aux États-Unis ça s'arrose ah
bah oui c'est ça
alors à part ça c'est quoi le projet que
tu as avec berger de avec Dupont un truc
danser c'est quoi avec ou sein Dupont
mais bon après c'est peut-être le temps
qui est dans ce sera drôle mais c'est
dedans c'est pas quelqu'un d'autre c'est
quoi l'histoire un peu comme ça
je peux pas le dire c'est un personnage
il va te dire tu es allé chez Ardisson
il t'a fait dire le projet je t'avais
dit de pas y aller je t'avais dit
non mais un peu comme ça je veux dire
pourquoi pas dire
c'est un show sur sur James
Dean enfin sur le mythead sur
sous-titré requiem pour un héros moderne
donc
il y a un autre canadien qui a l'affiche
en ce moment c'est Marc Drouin alors
c'est un type qui a beaucoup de succès
au Québec il a il a fait deux fois 200
fois 200 représentation à Montréal
[Musique]
c'est un humoriste c'est c'est un auteur
original et c'est un showman
je suis un groupe
tous les jours je ne le répète tu es en
vie tant
je commence à être un bon bide
quand on me raconte dans la rue on parle
en Biton ouais ben je réponds habitants
oui j'adore
oui je bois en béton puis je mange en
béton tout le monde
mais moi moi je rêve juste d'être un
inconnu
un individu qui marche dans une rue à
New York et Mr Lennon
alors
plan on va faire une interview
Charlebois
ça a été un dieu maintenant c'est un
chanteur comme un autre
ça va du frêne
ça a été mon interprète pendant j'ai
écrit 75 chansons pour elle
je peux plus l'avoir en personne mais
ni en peinture on m'avait offert un
tableau qui est un portrait d'elle que
que j'ai mis dans un placard par contre
je la considère encore comme la plus
grande interface francophone Johnny
Hallyday
j'en ai
j'étais à Los Angeles deux semaines en
octobre dernier enregistré quatre
chansons que j'ai écrit sur des musiques
de David Hallyday et depuis j'en ai plus
jamais de nouvelles il est revenu
et j'ai revenu en disant c'est génial on
va faire tout un album ensemble et le
patron de la maison
n'aime pas les chansons
alors j'attends toujours le résultat de
la bataille mais c'est pas reagil qui
travaille un peu avec lui en ce moment
ouais bon très bien toute façon pas du
tout
et moi et plusieurs autres heures donc
enfin sur quatre chansons il m'en
restera peut-être deux et si les gens il
y en aura d'autres pour les chanter bien
entendu Florent Pagny bah voilà alors
Barbara tu as dit humainement on est
réconcilié mais financièrement on est
toujours pas réconcilié c'est vrai que
les 10 passions ça pas été un triomphe
il faut bien le dire
non mais Barbara bon c'est une femme
pour qui j'ai toujours une très grande
admiration le jour où elle m'a demandé
d'écrire pour elle je pensais que
qu'elle ne faisait parfois des tests
j'ai mis une semaine à la rappeler elle
m'a dit dedans il y en a qui m'aurait
rappelé dans le matin à 9h et me dit je
veux que tu sois chez moi impérativement
ce soir à 6h et elle m'a envoyé sa
voiture et j'ai travaillé avec elle
pendant et ça a été un moment
extraordinaire dans ma vie bon et non
elle est venue voir Starmania je suis
allé la voir au Châtelet ça va on est
très amis tu dis que vous êtes fâchés
détails de droit mais comme il y a pas
eu beaucoup de droits c'est peut-être le
problème
Françoise Hardy
Françoise Hardy et c'est une des
premières personnes qui m'a demandé une
chanson et quand j'étais en train
d'écrire cette Armani avec berger un
jour j'ai répondu au téléphone il vient
de voir qui a dit ici Françoise Hardy et
à chaque fois je pense j'ai vraiment
pensé que c'était un gag et deux jours
après j'étais chez moi et alors je lui
ai fait une chanson je lui ai fait de
Françoise Hardy et je vais apporter ça
elle m'a dit non j'aime pas du tout elle
m'a dit j'aurais aimé qu'on me fassiez
une chanson comme j'ai rencontré l'homme
de ma vie ou chanson pour Elvis qui fait
des chansons que j'avais fait pour dire
une phrase chez moi j'ai fait une
chanson
Mylène Farmer
c'est assez allergique à mes enfants je
dois dire honnêtement physiquement
[Musique]
mais j'avoue que ça commence à me rendre
dedans et que je commence à je commence
à m'énerver moins qu'elle m'énerve je
détestais libertine et là je commence à
je sais pas pourquoi
mais finalement je me dis que non il y a
un style à la langue si tu veux je mets
pas la première chance j'aimais pas la
première fois mais à la longue il y a un
style et finalement les gens qui ont un
style souvent les impôts au début et on
les aime après et je trouve qu'il y a
une ligne directrice dans ce qu'elle
fait et les petites là Vanessa Paradis
Elsa tout ça tu en penses quoi
Vanessa Paradis ça ça me pour le moment
ça me laisse indifférent je chante bien
mais ce qu'elle chante me laisse
indifférent Vanessa Paradis ça me donne
un petit frisson
j'ai écrit une chanson qui s'appelle
Lolita que j'aimerais bien qu'elle
chante mais voilà
alors
vous n'êtes pas nombreux tu sais toute
façon c'est ça ça tourne en vrai et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater
[Musique]
un pouce bleu